Bailey being the acting returning
officer for the East worthing and
shoreham constituency hereby give notice
that the total number of votes given for
each candidate at this election was as
follows James Edward Doyle greens 2605
Michael Joseph Glennon known as Mike
Glennon you Kip 8,000 267 Timothy Paul
loudoun conservative 24,000 686
Tim McPherson labor nine thousand seven
hundred and thirty-seven robert john
Smitherman known as bob Smitherman
liberal democrats 3360 and Col John
Walker National Health Action Party 1243
and I hereby declare that the said
Timothy Paul Alton has been duly elected
to serve as a member of parliament for
East worthing and shoreham constituency
thank you guys for turning off her mr.
returning officer ladies and gentle can
I echo the thanks of Peter earlier to
Alex and to all his staff for the
counting it has been a long night thank
you for heightening the suspense by
leaving the result 22 now can I also
thank Worthing in ada councils for the
better backdrop they have provided this
year at the last election behind us was
a basketball net sponsored by mcdonalds
this year we have something rather more
appropriate and respectable can I also
pay tribute to all the other candidates
for a good clean honest fight politics
at its best and I want to single out two
candidates i would pay tribute to Tim
McPherson who has worked hard has been
in lots of places I wish he hadn't been
at times and has fought this campaign
well and I know for my experience of
fighting a majority of 23,000 labor in
Sheffield how it's not an easy task when
I congratulate Tim just as David
Blunkett was kind enough to congratulate
me and I also want to single out Bobby
smitherman
whoo-hoo usually doesn't need anybody
speak on his behalf with or without a
bell but bobby was thrown in at the last
minute and to take up the candidature
for his party is no mean feat and I
think he's done a fantastic job on
social media and off social media at
times as well can I also pay tribute to
my team and my helpers we have a
fantastic team in each worthing and
shoreham and i want to thank
particularly the team around me james
butcher annoyingly at times who's made
us kept us going to Juliet to Harry to
Hugh an old friend from eastbourne who
I'm glad that we've won back today and
also to my wife who has seen more of me
in the last five weeks because she's
been knocking on the doors every day
with me than she has in the last five
years in Parliament it is a huge
privilege to represent the people of
East worthing and shoreham it's been a
privilege over the last 18 years it's a
particular privilege to have a record
number of votes this time and I war do
my utmost to repay the confidence that
has been paid in me one last point
somebody sent me an email yesterday
saying that they were embarrassed to be
living in a Tory stronghold this is not
a Tory stronghold we have never taken
this seat for granted we did not win
this election in the last five weeks we
won it in the last five years by being
out every week every weekend with the
people engaging as politicians should do
so I'm not embarrassed about this
constituency
and I'm proud and I'm proud to represent
people who have cast their vote today to
cast their confidence in a government
that will keep us on the economic track
back to recovery that will make work pay
that will show that you can only live
within your means and that will and is
the only party that will and can deliver
a vote to the people on our future
relationship with Europe whatever that
may be I'm grateful for your support
it's back to work tomorrow for my
shoreham councillors there'll be a
street surgery in the farmers market
this saturday and we'll be back on the
case of the a27 of our excellent
worthing hospital and all the other very
important issues affecting this
constituency thank you for your support
I hope to repair it again over the next
five years thank you very much